you've built a business that you
bootstrapped over 500 million dollars in
Revenue I wanted to run a hobby business
I just got this crazy idea that my hobby
business was going to be like sending
grass-fed beef to people's houses I'm
not a big believer in business plans
because uh every time I've written one
their body changed right away you could
have written the whole business plan
then you literally went to Whole Foods
they're like oh [ __ ] it's wrong
my first purpose was like I'm gonna
prove that I can start a hobby business
and not raise outside Capital chip on my
shoulder and then you get to a point
where you're like okay that's done
what's next butcher box has always
revealed another deeper purpose for me
to be going for all right guys bang bang
I've got Mike here uh you've built a
business that you bootstrap or is no
outside money to over 500 million
dollars in Revenue which makes you seem
like an absolute genius and a bunch of
people are like how the hell did he do
that we'll talk about that in a second
uh you also previously raised 30 million
dollars for a company that you learned a
lot of uh things not to do doing talk a
little bit about kind of that first big
experience trying to build a business
raise a bunch of money and like it not
work out and kind of how you thought
about hey where do we screw up and like
what lessons did we learn so that then
it set the ground for butcher box to
eventually become this huge business
yeah for sure
um so
I was 26 years old uh my co-founder and
I were best friends and we wanted to do
something we didn't know what we were
going to do but we had to find something
to start or to run get rich yeah uh get
rich that's right um and it was like a
very financially motivated very much
American dream like we want to like do
something ourselves make money stop
having a boss and uh my my co-founder
loved custom woodworking he had just
bought a coffee table on this website
custommade.com and he's talking to the
the woodworker who made his table and
the Woodworkers like I get all my work
from custom made and I pay 35 a year for
my subscription this is like a two
thousand dollar coffee table and so
we're like this is great like everything
you search for around custom furniture
if you typed in custom made bookshelf or
custom-made desk custom-made.com showed
up first and these guys were cleaning up
so we bought the website off of a guy
for a hundred forty thousand dollars why
did he sell it for so cheap it was four
that was four times Revenue so you know
I um I had been transitioning out of a
job and I had written him months prior
and then when I left the job my last job
that I worked for someone he wrote me
like two two days later and was like
I'll sell
and so we didn't have 140 000 we uh put
down five thousand dollars and had 90
days due diligence where we ran around
town uh ran around Boston trying to
convince people to give us money
um and this is like 2008 right when
Bernie Madoff just ran off with
everyone's money in Boston so it was
like it's a tough time to be raising
money
um it's funny they say 2008 Bernie
Madoff not Global financial crisis like
the bigger thing was Bernie made out oh
in Boston I mean like if you were the
the people we were connected to and
trying to raise money from in Boston had
like just just been personally impacted
by Bernie Madoff Jesus and they're
pissed or like they're like real fast
like okay uh yeah all my money went to
him and now it's gone
um and so we bought this website and we
started this subscription business where
these uh Woodworkers would pay an annual
fee to be on the site and we tried to
like upgrade the site but just I mean we
made so many mistakes on that website
how many of the mistakes are on the
website were uh you're young and didn't
know versus like you had this theory of
we'll make more money or it'll be a
better product if we do X and like your
assumption was just wrong at the
beginning it was really like we were
young and we didn't know like you know I
look at entrepreneurship now and um I
think it's a lot better resource than it
was like if you don't know how to build
a website you can find that information
in 2008 like I didn't feel like there
were a lot of people out there who could
explain to us like here's what you do
and here's what you don't do there's
podcasts there's blogs there's Twitter
there's like all this stuff and then you
also like know many more of the people
yeah who've been doing this for now you
know a decade plus after 2008 yeah that
you can reach out to and ask right and
so we didn't have any of that we built a
website that was really bad
um
and you know we had all these makers
calling in complaining about how all
their work dried up the SEO dried up we
just like it was a nightmare it was a
nightmare and it kept crashing and is
there a moment where you're like all
right we raised some money we bought the
website we thought we were improving it
oh [ __ ] we may have actually been
destroying it like is there like a one
moment where that like hits you uh that
was pretty much every day
I mean we just we just did our best to
just destroy all the value we purchased
um so then we we raised a little more
money all of this was friends and family
at this point so we had gotten up to
like a million dollars of raised Capital
mostly people that we had worked with
before in real estate and then we
decided you know everyone's like raising
money from VCS like we should go raise
money from VCS of course yeah so we go
out in like uh what was it it was
um the summer of 2011. so we go out in
2011.
and we're going around with like Hey
we're a woodworker listing service and
every VC is like hell no woodworker
listing service not in a million years
like not a venture thing this won't work
blah blah blah blah
but nevertheless like we were really
good at persistence and sales so we just
kept going kept going kept going and I
remember this moment like vividly uh we
we built this feature called the job
board where
um a customer could like say I'm looking
for a custom bookshelf in Lake Placid
New York and then a local maker could
like bid on it and say hey I could do
that for you and the reason why we built
it is because when um when we would call
these these Woodworkers and say hey we
have this it's like there's all this
work on here you should join they were
like well how do I know they'll be work
and so we built this publicly facing job
board that we would say oh here's your
ZIP code look there's been three posts
today that you could respond to anyway
so I'm in this VC meeting and I'm like
pull up the job board and pull it up and
I'm like all we have to do is stand in
between these transactions and they're
literally like coming in it's like boom
oh so it's like working it's working
yeah people are posting stuff yeah you
ever seen a live demo that worked and
we're like all we have to do is stand in
between these transactions and we'll
have the largest Marketplace for custom
stuff
and as soon as I said the word
Marketplace everything changed like the
VCS went from like no no no to like
Marketplace you could be the next Airbnb
I'm like yeah of course yeah if that's
what it's gonna take like no problem yes
we could be the next Airbnb and they're
like great we're in
and so
we're in right Marketplace on the top of
the website well and I think you know
it's like um I have a lot to say about
VCS in my experience but one of the
things that's really important is that
the VCS are pattern matchers right so if
you're out raising money
um the more that you can point to this
being like part of a pattern that
they're currently very interested in
like they say yes that's just how it
works so in 2011 everyone was trying to
chase the next Marketplace Uber had just
gone out Airbnb like people are like I
can't miss the next Marketplace and that
that worked so we raised like two
million dollars uh five months later we
raised another four and then a year
later we raised 18.
um and so it went from like nobody
wanted to touch this thing to like
everybody wanted to touch this thing now
the problem was that the business that
we were selling people on this
marketplace where we were going to stand
in between a maker and a buyer it didn't
work like
nobody wanted to actually transact that
way so like so there were lots of people
interested in projects but they
generally were very fickle they'd fall
apart the maker would pull them off off
platform because it was easier for them
and for a whole host of reasons it just
like I was interested in the custom
bookcase until you told me it was twenty
thousand dollars yeah exactly like I
want I Ikea prices but I want it to be
custom and so we had a really hard time
betting people and building a liquid
Marketplace but because we had raised
all this money and because we had said
the word Marketplace and because that's
what people invested in it was very hard
to unwind it and be like hey you know
what we're just going to be a
subscription business now like we
couldn't be and so we had the
subscription business that was like a
pretty decent business before we raised
a bunch of money and we just like we we
got stuck and then it became like okay
well it's got to be your team that's the
problem so we had um you know uh Google
so Google was one of our investors
they're like hey do you want us to send
our Engineers around just to like I
don't know poke around do an audit of
what's happening on your site and we're
like yeah of course like Google that's
awesome
you know they come in they're like yeah
this is bad like you you guys need to
scrap this whole thing and rebuild it
and we're like oh [ __ ] okay and so over
the course of a year we uh thanks for
your opinion but uh go back yeah well I
didn't have the confidence to say that
that's what I should have said yeah
right what did you say what I did
instead is I was we're gonna fix this
and we ended up
um
basically firing everybody
um and so I heard this analogy once of a
startup being like you're hacking
Through the Jungle with machetes and
you're just looking for a trail
somewhere and what you need is people
who just have you know are Relentless at
hacking and finding a trail and then
they find a trail and maybe that trail
leaves their dirt road and in in the
custom-made business
um we got to this dirt road there was a
nice shiny Google funded bus on the dirt
road and I was like I don't think you
guys know how to drive
and I left them all in the jungle all of
them so all my friends all the people
who like built this thing from the
beginning all the people that were in
the trenches with me
we left them all
um
and that is by far my biggest regret of
the whole experience were they pissed
yeah I mean yes and no it depends and
some of them actually are now working
for me at butcherbox which is cool
um some understood it they understood
like the pressures we were under but
yeah a lot were super pissed yeah
because they helped me build this thing
and then at the very at the very moment
where it became like oh we we attracted
outside investment because of all the
things you did we're like you're not
good enough
um and uh I mean it's never it's never
easy to let people go and to do it on
your terms instead of theirs so yeah so
you do that how do you get from like
we've raised whatever 30 million dollars
whatever it ends up being to like okay
this doesn't work like it's over
so it went something like this first it
was the circular firing squad like this
must be an engineering problem this must
be a product problem this must be a
marketing problem like basically every
Department Department by Department it's
their fault it's their fault is
therefore everyone's problem but
Google's everyone's everyone's problem
except like the investment thesis might
not have been the right one then it
became our problem so my co-founder and
I uh it was like we don't think you guys
are the right people it's like okay
uh so then they made us like wave wave
rights and you know kind of
um
did it get nasty yeah a little a little
nasty can uh whatever you're allowed to
say uh you could take out names whatever
but like I think there's a lot of people
who only see the positive side yeah of
like interacting with investors
what can you tell me about the nasty
part of it like did they pressure you
guys to do things yeah yeah like how did
that work yeah so the nastiest thing
that happened was we had negotiated as
uh all should do that despite the fact
that we had investors that when it came
to management decisions
um including uh replacing ourselves that
that was up to us right and so if you
have if you're raising if you're raising
capital and it's competitive you can get
something like that put in there uh most
Founders don't even know that they
should negotiate for that so we
negotiated for that and uh at the end it
was like you need to waive that because
we're gonna try to replace you and we
want you to waive that so if we find
someone great like we can replace you
and we were like no like you what do you
mean you already like you already
negotiated for that and and they
basically were like we're gonna
blackball you we're gonna make sure you
don't raise any more money and you'll be
dead yep you're gonna erase it and we're
like
okay like sure you know you you back
down pretty fast yeah uh at least we
back down pretty fast now
you know uh if you could go back to that
moment now knowing everything you know
what would you have done
like just hold the [ __ ] off well the pro
the problem with the business was we
were we were like look we're burning 500
000 a month five hundred thousand
dollars a month a lot of money we're
like this business is We're not gonna
make it like there's a wall we're gonna
run out of money we're not gonna make it
we need to like dramatically reduce
staff change our business model do
something different like and and our our
investors were like no
um I got it you know like basically at
first it was well we're gonna try to
replace you guys as CEO or us CEO Mike
uh and we want a new CFO a CEO to see
like a full company of people
that was their reasoning and then after
that it was like well we're going to try
to sell and we want the new company to
see like lots of people
and like neither of those were very good
investment philosophies but nevertheless
we kept burning money
um and so at the very end we had taken a
um small Venture debt line as part of
the 18 million
and that bank was like
your bank balance is below what you owe
us and none of your investors are
willing to Pony up anymore we want to do
uh what they call a friendly foreclosure
so they basically did a foreclosure
um friendly they just throw that in for
yeah yeah just to make a sound better
just to make you like you know smile
while they do it no as I understand it
like um you know a lot of these Venture
Banks work kind of on the side of
venture capital firms right so they they
have lots of deals together and so it's
basically like they're playing a
long-term game with each other they're
like look we we're the debt provider we
come out first there's not enough debt
here like we don't get the big return
you're the equity provider
kill this deal and we you know the next
one will take care of you
um and so ended up getting foreclosed on
we uh fired everybody
um then my co-founder uh the Relentless
bastard uh went back took it out of
bankruptcy took four of the people who
were still there and is still running
the company but but did all everything
we wanted to do pivoted it you know
leaned out the team did all the things
and wiped all the equity holders so like
everyone got zero none of the original
investors benefit correct post uh and
neither does the debt yep got it so the
only saving grace of the whole thing on
investment wise is uh as part of the 18
because the the deal was so
oversubscribed
um we were able to do secondary so we
were we were able to offer all of our
original like friends and family 3x
their money we were able to take some
off the table small but like we were
able to take some off the table uh that
was the only saving grace otherwise I
would have been seven years lost
everyone's money and had nothing to show
for it how many of the friends and
family took the secondary most okay not
my mother that's better well that's bad
but that's better than I have faith in
you it's like yeah no Mom please don't
next time it's like Mom this is it take
it uh but like what's interesting to me
is obviously secondaries became very
popular especially last year in 2021 and
uh
every single mathematical formula you
could think of outside of this is the
next Facebook this is the next Airbnb
this is the next one I mean not even
near me but like you know these big
companies you should take some yeah of
the money off the table uh even if it's
just one x what you invested so you
don't lose money on the deal right right
now you're playing with house money
whatever but because it's been so
celebratized and like it's so sexy to be
the seed investor or whatever in like
the next unicorn that becomes the like
100 plus billion dollar company
nobody was taking secondaries except for
many of the founders were taking a
second reason right but none of the
early investors were like oh my God you
know such and such firmware this
firmware this firm is like coming in
like they're smart so like I'm just
gonna ride it right and so it's very
fascinating because like actually the
math tells you to take the deal or at
least part of the deal but like
psychology takes over and humans are
dumb and we're just like screw it let's
Let It Ride well one way that companies
manufacture that um is that they they
they make it all or nothing on secondary
so they say you have to sell your entire
position
um or nothing and so in a lot of cases
then people are like well do I want to
sell everything but in the cases where
you're actually able to sell a piece
like I don't see any reason why you
shouldn't be selling a piece especially
because you know they're I think what
the past year has taught all of us is
like uh everything looks great when
you're riding high but when the tide
goes out like you want to make sure you
have a little bit of liquidity in your
in your back pocket so you get into bad
times yes thankfully friends and family
for the most part are okay yes they
wanted the grand slam they got a single
fine uh how do you go from that to
butcher box yeah so um I actually had
all of these designs to take 100 days
off I had a five-month-old daughter at
the time
and uh she's not five months anymore no
yeah she's grown up a little bit she's
eight now
um
yeah so I had a five-month-old daughter
and I was like you know I'm just gonna
like I'm gonna take a hundred days off
and just like lick my wounds and maybe
go to Meditation Retreat and like figure
out what's what uh I ended up taking the
weekend off
and then starting butcher box
um and uh I did because that's so
gracious of you yeah
Memorial Day it was a long weekend it
was got an extra day there
um so I I had been so my wife uh has an
autoimmune uh condition
um a thyroid condition and we were
following all these
um elimination diets like
anti-inflammation diets to like help her
with her uh with her condition and they
also had to eat grass-fed beef and uh we
couldn't find it
um couldn't find it in the grocery store
or maybe there'd be ground beef but
there wouldn't be anything else and I
just became obsessed with this like well
how do you get grass-fed beef and I
ended up like in the last year as
custom-made was was failing I ended up
uh starting to buy uh cow shares from
different Farmers local farmers what is
that uh cow share is where you buy like
half a cow and so you get like two
massive trash bags full of meat uh
that's all different cuts from a cow
um and so the the cow share was too big
to fit in my freezer so I started
selling it to like my friends so I
basically like you know split it up like
a drug dealer and um get my little head
stash for you know for free uh diluting
yeah yeah diluting exactly
um and so you know somebody was like
somebody who was in my office was like
this would be so much better if it's
just delivered to my house and I was
like oh you were like saying like hey
you can come buy it but you gotta like
come to mind yeah well well no they were
um I would bring it to work and it was
like people from work who would buy all
these shares off of me
um and he's like this would be so much
better if it's delivered to my house I
was like yeah that would be better and
at the time I was looking for uh I
wanted to run a hobby business and I
wanted it to be like modeled after like
the Tim Ferriss four-hour work week I'm
going to be living in Argentina I'm
gonna pick up my laptop look at it for
10 minutes close my laptop go about my
day and I thought a subscription
business especially because of my
experience with custom made that a
subscription business would be like much
better because
um there it's recurring Revenue so once
you get it going it's just like like it
just feeds on itself and so I just got
this crazy idea that my hobby business
was going to be like sending grass-fed
beef to people's houses
um and so I uh I didn't know how to like
put all the pieces together I didn't
know how to I mean I ate me but I knew
I'm not a meat guy
um I didn't know how to buy me I didn't
know how to ship me I didn't know like
the first thing about any of it did you
with this owner before we kind of get
all the way into what you did you're
doing this for like a year just kind of
poking around buying this is like uh uh
me plus leftovers yeah right
did you like run actual tests like did
you like set up a website I think or was
it like oh this sounds cool it could be
a hobby business like we're starting a
business yeah so the idea was so first
of all I didn't know how to do anything
and then I met I I hunted down the
former head of operations of Omaha
Stakes which are the people who come to
like your house and like try to sell you
steaks uh they they do that very rarely
but yes they do do some of that but it's
a you know it's a 500 million dollar
gift giving business
um been around for 100 years uh catalog
and direct mail and all that
um
and so he was the guy who like knew how
to buy the product how to ship the
product interesting so I reached out to
him on LinkedIn and he's like yeah my
non-compete ended like I'll help you out
and so then pieces started coming
together it's like oh okay here's how
you do it he's like here are some farms
and here's like the shipping facility
and like so things started to coming
coming together
and so when I was leaving custom made
um to me it was like I could either wait
and like kind of lick my wounds and
figure things out or I could just get
started on this new Venture as fast as
possible it's like a rebound yeah and
um because I didn't think it was going
to be very big
like I was I was literally like if I
have a thousand subscribers and I make
twenty dollars per subscriber it's
twenty thousand dollars in gross profit
I'll Outsource some stuff to like a
couple Filipinos and I'll probably be
able to bring like 10 to 12 000 a month
and like cover my nut that was it that
was like that was it that's the Dream
from this is a dream I like to say that
I failed miserably at that dream like
that that is not what happened
um but and the other thing was I thought
that so the way I wanted to start was
via Kickstarter because
with custom made it was a two-sided
Marketplace so there's a buyer and a
seller and so as CEO of custom made I
went to school on like marketplaces and
Marketplace Dynamics and
um and there's this there's these points
of time in marketplaces where they they
reach like saturation on the internet
and then there's huge opportunity for
people who know to how to play by the
rules
um so early days eBay it was like there
used to be stores where they would sell
your stuff for you because they knew how
to like write good descriptions and take
good photos nowadays eBay has figured
out how to like make that all part of
like the app and that opportunity is
gone but it was it was a big opportunity
for a long time Amazon Marketplace Etsy
Marketplace people are taking advantage
of these arbitrages I thought
Kickstarter was like Rife for that and
it was so um our whole our whole
thing was to get the kickstarter
verified badge because we we noticed
that Kickstarter verified put you on the
home page put you on the top of the food
page put you in search
um Kickstarter would send a Tweet about
you like they would do all these things
and so we tried to deconstruct how do
you get Kickstarter verified which was
one part like blowing through your goal
in the first day and one part momentum
and like we just how did you deconstruct
that so like you realize just about this
stuff we just started analyzing all the
ones that worked with yeah we'd like
look at things that um went live and
like oh look they got the badge oh they
got the badge like right after they did
XYZ so just kind of like became students
of what was happening on Kickstarter and
so we launched in September so I took
off Memorial Day weekend and I actually
had an intern
um who I paid ten dollars an hour start
with me on the Tuesday after Memorial
Day uh because I was really worried
about starting a business by myself like
I did didn't think I'd have the
discipline to like actually work all the
time
um
so uh but I knew if somebody was there
like this I know I can't take more than
four days off but like I'm actually
worried I can't do the work yeah and I
just I just thought I would just like
sit on the couch and like you know
um not work but I knew if somebody was
there being like all right what's the
next mic I'd be like uh okay do this and
that's how we got going
um an intern is much better than a
co-founder at that yes absolutely I mean
I I yeah I I think um you know a lot of
businesses fail because of co-founder
Dynamics
um I'm blessed to still be very close
with my co-founder from my first company
but I never want to have a co-founder
again
[Laughter]
great guy but that awesome guy is just
like when the decision when when the
decision has to be like there needs to
be somebody in charge yeah even if
they're a co-founder you need to figure
out like okay who's in charge here
though and I think most great businesses
even if there are multiple co-founders
uh three four five whatever they if you
even ask them like who has the final say
yeah they all defer to one person uh if
the business ends up being great yep
because if not there becomes all kinds
of issues and I've also seen companies
that said okay we're going to draw a
line in the sand all the decisions that
relate to acts this co-founder decides
all the other ones this co-founder
decides and like even that's a little
messy sometimes yeah but at least there
is some you know final decision maker
that everyone agrees on for that
specific topic yeah we had a card so
ours was like um
uh the decision card so if we were at a
impasse and could not make a decision
together
um then somebody who started my
co-founder started with a card it was
like he could be like I'm pulling the
card and then whatever the decision is
like
we go with what he wants to do yep but
then I get the card
oh that's slick yeah so it's like you
better use it on something good because
then I'm gonna have the card and you're
not gonna have the card he actually
never pulled the card so you never got
the card either yeah I never got the
card
so I don't know if it worked or didn't
but uh we we ended up being able to
settle all disputes
um with uh just a lot of arguing all
right so you got butcher box you're is
it do you know what the name of this
thing is at the beginning or yeah well I
started with meet with a name.com which
would have been really bad meet with a
name meet with a name because like the
animal has a name because it's being
well cared for uh and then I'm glad you
did yeah no that would have been bad
yeah then a buddy of mine was like what
about butcherbox uh and butcherbox.com
was taken
um by uh did you get it we got it uh two
years into the business it was a butcher
in McLean Virginia and uh he had built
it because he wanted to do butcher boxes
and ship them out and um so we had get
butcherbox.com for a long or for a few
years and then I just kept harassing him
and finally he's like I'll sell you fine
um how much I think we paid 10 grand for
it and at that point it was like that's
a no-brainer let's do it yeah
yeah so uh we came up with the name
butcher box the first thing that
happened was we I sent my intern out to
like Whole Foods to talk to people about
uh how much meat were they buying per
per visit or per month how much did they
pay for different types of meat
um how much do they know about grass-fed
beef
um and what we learned within one day of
just surveying people is
um our model which was going to be we
were going to ship a box of grass-fed
beef was just not going to work because
people don't eat that much beef in a
month and so people are like I would
definitely sign up for something if it
had chicken and pork and beef but I'm
not going to do it for just beef and so
we immediately were like okay butcher
boxes not just beef we're gonna do beef
chicken and pork our Kickstarter was
um beef chicken and pork and you could
choose which box you wanted like all
beef beef and pork beef chicken and pork
um were you worried that that introduced
complexity either on the user side or on
like the operation side yeah it well it
definitely increased a little bit of
complexity on the operation side because
now you're dealing with like three
different species instead of one and you
have to figure out like what the
grass-fed equivalent is for pigs or for
chickens or whatever
um but it was definitely what the member
wanted and I wanted to be able to ship a
box every month to the member and it
just wasn't going to work if it was beef
so it just it just got more you had to
do it yeah but the thing that we did uh
so again so we start
I'm like I'm only gonna put ten thousand
dollars into this company I'm not
raising any money because it's supposed
to be a hobby and like all right 10
grand I can recoup that this will work
um and so less than 10 grand to start
the company uh Kickstarter all that and
the other thing that we did because we
didn't have any money is
um we sent out a what we call the
curated box so if you chose beef and
chicken we're gonna send you beef and
chicken but we're gonna send you
whatever we want like you don't get a
choice as the customer
um we've since changed that now we have
like a custom box and you can choose
from like 50 different products and
whatnot but at the time in order to not
have to carry any inventory we basically
were like we're gonna send you whatever
so the the January box would be like
here are the cuts that are going to be
in the January box so we could bring in
the inventory run through the inventory
bring in more inventory for February and
keep going so this is interesting
because you raised no money yeah so for
those that don't know uh normally you
would have to raise money you then would
go spend a bunch of money on marketing
acquire customers and then those
customers uh would almost be like just
in time customers because you may get
them on Tuesday ship a box out on
Wednesday and like you're playing an
inventory game which you're talking
about here
because you weren't holding in the
inventory did you tell people like hey
you have to be subscribed by like
January 14th to get the box that ships
on like January 21st like how did you
operationalize not being overextended
not having to put a bunch of money in
it's a new race car
Maybe
chili no
[Music]
crypto trading apps okay we
um so we did hold the inventory we just
ran it so tight that um so boxes were
always going out okay and um the place
that we started with had a cutting
facility attached to the shipping
facility smart so we were able to like
move stuff uh pretty pretty quickly
pretty just in time
um and they were actually I mean you
know one of the things that I say about
people are like how did you grow the
business without raising money like I'm
stuck with inventory what do I do uh and
one of the things was the company that
cut our meat was actually remarkably bad
at invoicing us for the meat so
you know it's like a 30 000 order of New
York strips they like forgot about for a
month and then would bill us for it just
so happens you got 30 000 of customer
Revenue yeah exactly exactly so we um we
yeah and they'll find dumb vendors who
have bad operations is a key component
to building a self-sustaining business
bad operations yeah so or a bad uh
billing department
um and then we ended up like over time
we've actually financed the inventory
using debt not how does that work just
for people who don't spend all the time
in software world like how do you
finance what would be inventory well so
it's a physical good right so it's a
it's a hunk of meat um and so that has a
value to it and so there are uh lending
institutions that will lend against
inventory
um and yeah so we uh we actually started
with our fulfillment center was like did
a program where they would Finance their
inventory and then there are lenders who
will finance against inventory uh and
you can get a pretty low rate because if
you default they get all your inventory
and that has like you know
they can get 70 cents on the dollar or
something like that for for selling it
um so as we got operations up and showed
that we were like profitable and like a
real thing uh we were able to do that
um which is yeah I mean inventory from
my experience in uh our business as well
as mentoring lots of other people
inventory is an area where I think a lot
of people like start thinking well I
need to raise money uh to fund inventory
and it's really a debt problem it's not
an equity problem and I think a lot of
people tune that's the point where
they're like okay I'm gonna go raise
money
um versus trying to figure out different
options different funding options to uh
Finance it so Tuesday after Memorial Day
when you start this thing uh you know
none of this yeah you're like emailing
or LinkedIn uh with Omaha Steak persons
yeah uh and you have an intern how do
you go from I don't know a stranger and
an intern to like okay we're live on
Kickstarter and like we get the verified
badge and like game on yeah so what do
you do there yeah so first we had to
um you know I had been playing around
with Kickstarter for a while trying to
figure out like what what happening here
and so we you have to have like a plan
of what you're going to do with
Kickstarter so for us it was like first
of all I want to be able to ship out
these boxes like pretty much immediately
like so our our Kickstarter was like
September 9th through October 8th and we
were shipping out Boxes by like the 20th
because we wanted to like get product in
people's hands and then roll them to a
subscriber
um so we just built a plan of like here
are all the things that we need to do
here are all the people that need to say
stuff and then it just became you know
we were into
um The Lean Startup book and just
running kind of
trying to trying to figure out how to
like
run tests uh understand what our
customers would like so we did a lot of
surveying a lot of like going to Whole
Foods a lot of like just getting in
front of people and asking them
questions
um and came up with like all right we
can launch this Kickstarter Campaign
which you need obviously you need
um a video for which I had a friend who
did stuff at custom made for us uh you
need like a brand which I had another
friend who uh ran a branding firm that
helped us with so I just compiled all
these people to kind of like help with
the the original unveiling and
um
yeah we uh
I I didn't want to spend a lot of money
because I wanted it to be a hobby
business and so really everything went
through that lens it's kind of like yeah
we can't do that because it's too much
or we can't we can't focus on custom
buying customers or and during
Kickstarter that like this we had this
big aha moment where um we had reached
out to like anybody on Twitter who had
mentioned grass fed before being like
Hey we're launching this company could
you give us some some press when we do
and there was this nutritionist uh this
paleo nutritionist called Chris Chris
cresser
uh he's a doctor in California with a
huge following and
um he tweeted when we had when we
launched on Kickstarter he tweeted about
it he was like I tell you to eat
grass-fed beef and this is like a great
great place to go to get it and we just
saw all of these signups happen like
right away like tons of activity on
Kickstarter
and we were like that's interesting
let's do more of that
um and so no Grand boardroom plan
influencer marketing it's like Chris the
doctor from California gotta subscribe
notice the signals who's Chris number
two yeah yeah notice the signals yeah I
mean okay so here's what I think about
like
in general in with entrepreneurship I
think people spend way too much time on
a business plan
uh and no time on a lifestyle design
and I think one of the like most
incredible things about being an
entrepreneur is you get to actually
Define
what you want your lifestyle to look
like
and so what I encourage people to do is
to go do like a visioning exercise of
your three years in the future like what
does your lifestyle look like what time
are you getting up what are you doing do
you have kids are you hanging out with
them in the morning are you like are you
doing hard workout like you know what
does that lifestyle look like
um I'm not a big believer in business
plans because uh every time I've written
one like they changed like right away
yeah they're completely [ __ ] for a
business that's starting because to your
point like you could have written the
whole business plan then you went
literally went to Whole Foods you're
like oh [ __ ] it's wrong right totally
and it anchors you on the wrong stuff
and then you're like kind of like our
first business you're like well this is
what we said we were gonna do
um and so in this business it was like
no we're just gonna like observe and
then make decisions based on our
observations and then just keep going
with this Relentless pursuit of like
helping the customer get what they want
um yeah and so influencers it was like I
guess we're doing influencers and then
we went hard after influencers and um
what do those deals look like in the
beginning are you just stroking checks
to them or how's it yeah know so we
didn't have any money so uh we couldn't
stroke checks um so what we did is we
reached out to these influencers
and the way we reached out to them we
used to call it our trojan horse is we
were like we were sending this box of
meat and it was curated and we would
like to throw in recipes about the
things we sent so if we send you uh back
ribs pork back ribs like and here's a
recipe on how to cook them and so what
we did is we went out to these
influencers and were like hey we saw
this back ribs recipe this whole 30 back
ribs recipe uh were butcher box we'd
like to include it in our box and like
put your name on it and a link to you
and all this stuff like would you be
okay with that and and everyone everyone
said yes because influencers appreciated
on like influencer influence and free
marketing and
and they're like oh by the way it was
butcher box and we're like oh let us
tell you what butcher box is um and you
know we're like oh we're the service
like yeah probably aligns really well
with your Audience by the way we can't
pay you to uh send an email but what we
can do is pay your residual so every
month that that subscriber maintains
their membership we can give you ten
dollars and we can give you fifteen
dollars or whatever the whatever the
deal was at the time what's the most
that anyone was making oh geez I mean we
still have people uh north of twenty
thousand dollars a month so there's some
people who are as a influencer slash
distribution partner whatever yeah uh
for butcher Bots are making a quarter of
a million dollars a year yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy amazing right yeah and so
for this for them it was it was amazing
for them yeah and we backed into this
like you know uh unbeknownst to us we
backed into this really interesting moat
because
there there have been other companies
that have come along and and sold meat
in the mail
um but what is the motivation of that
influencer to go like work with them
when they're already like getting this
like residual income stream for they
don't have to do really no work yeah
they don't have to do anything else and
that's right I just don't get my twenty
thousand dollars that's why people don't
leave so are you really gonna like go
hawk some other product and and destroy
that income stream probably not yeah so
we yeah we just like stumbled upon this
like pretty sweet thing and we went hard
after uh if you were like in paleo
Whole30 CrossFit keto like you almost
definitely wrote about about butcherbox
at some point
um and we actually were like I don't I
want to make sure it's not like oh we
gamed everything like we actually
provide a product that people were
looking for yeah and Their audience was
looking for so it was like a win-win on
both sides how much of it was the
gamification slash marketing and you
guys are smart there versus like nah
even if we weren't good at that stuff
like the people wanted this box and so
we would still have a pretty good
business even with just the box with
without being experts on the market yeah
I think the to start with it really was
that people really wanted the box and
the this is true today as well but the
the industry for what what we call
claims-based meat but like meat raised
better we can get into all the what what
that means
um
in 2015 and 16 and 17 was really nascent
and people had like read uh Michael
pollan's omnivores dilemma or had like
read some of these blog posts that I had
read and were like I want to make a
change okay where do I go and there's
like
nowhere to go and then all the Farms
that you could buy from were really
inefficient because it would sell like
half a cow which is two massive trash
bags full of meat like where are you
gonna put that
um or there'd be Farms that would Ship
Direct but they would have to you'd have
to like get it overnighted so it was
like 150 in shipping to send you like 20
worth of meat you had to be a hardcore
yeah and like big time believer with big
dollars behind you in order to do kind
of the traditional way you guys
basically brought a lower cost option to
the that's right to the table that's
right uh and then as we've scaled the
industry because at at our size we're
now like scaling the industry uh We've
we've continued to do it more and more
efficiently to drive a better and better
value to people so that they can
actually afford to eat this way whereas
like five years ago that was not the
case so we're like screwing around we're
like oh yeah this like small thing with
an intern whatever like you make over
500 million dollars a year you guys have
raised new outside Capital right 500
million dollars in Revenue per year is a
[ __ ] crazy number thank you uh how do
you go from like oh we were at Whole
Foods and like somebody told us like go
include chicken
500 million dollars a year in Revenue
yeah so what does that scaling look like
so our Revenue path was uh so we did
about 300 000 in the first uh year
um 2015 we launched Kickstarter in
September so we did the kickstarter and
then we had like some follow-on
subscribers so three hundred thousand
dollars then we did 5 million then we
did 33 million so like those are five
extra business six over six extra
business you know 33 million then a
hundred million then 225 million
um and then covet hit so we went from
225 to 450 so we didn't think we were
going to double but then we doubled the
business again and then we did 450 to
550 last year so like slowing down a
little bit you can't triple and double
yeah it turns out you can't
um and then this year we don't know
where we'll end up uh we were hoping to
be north of six but I think that's gonna
be pretty tough just given the
um just the environment will definitely
be above last year but it's gonna so 300
to 5 is a big [ __ ] leap right for any
founder that's out there was like I got
to 300 they're like okay maybe this
works maybe double yourself questions
right five is like I got a business yeah
right uh is that all influencers no so
influencers was like
really got us to like 35 uh and then and
then we started doing well what happened
how do you get from 300 to five you get
a 300K to 5 million yeah so that's what
influencers okay all right five to
Thirty whatever you said deep
influencers that's like a stupid jump
yeah right if you had investors they
would be like in the lp update you're
the first company right they're like hey
this butcher box went from five million
to 30 million yeah look how smart we are
yeah that's all influencers too yup so
you basically got a 30 million in
Revenue in two years ish uh just going
to people and being like do you want to
be included in the box and like can you
tweet about it that's wild yep and we I
mean we we we built a very large program
very quickly we were maniacal about like
reaching out to everybody
um and you guys are profitable this
entire time yeah always been pretty much
from day one yeah
so when we got to 33 though
um it became harder and harder to scale
um and so what we did we thought we had
enough cash flow coming in what we did
is so every every single subscriber that
we signed up for the first two and a
half years had to be what I called box
one profitable which means we had to
make money on you as a customer that
first box fully loaded so we'd call it
dollars per box so we knew the amount of
dollars that we were making off of every
box let's say it's 25 and so we knew
that we had 25 to acquire you as a
customer and then if we acquired you for
less than 25 dollars when you
resubscribed which 90 of the people
would or whatever
um it's all it's all gravy from there
right and so that's how we built the
business so then you've got this bolus
of subscribers who are starting to fund
the business and you're profitable on
the first customers after a while we
were like this isn't going to work
anymore we need to dip into month two so
then we it was like okay we'll spend the
profit of box one and to on acquiring
that Customer because we had a little
bit more cash flow and we're like not
feeling like we're suffocating all the
time and you also understood better
about the retention that's right like we
we knew hey they buy the first box
you're probably gonna buy the second
yeah we we were then understanding our
lifetime value curves how long a
customer would stay for what they were
going to buy how we could influence that
and improve that
um and so yeah I mean we fast forward to
now we're spending way deeper than two
months in because we know what the
customer we know the right customers to
try to purchase and then we know
um
yeah we we know how to keep them
when you start to get the machine going
how many people are working at the
business at this time it's just like you
the intern the Omaha Stakes person and
like another person or are you at like
25 people 50 people like no no yeah we
were we were pretty we were pretty uh
lean for uh several years so uh and and
mostly with uh interns people who didn't
people who had a chip on their shoulder
something to prove and didn't really
have any knowledge of what we were doing
um and so we uh yeah we brought in a
uh Juan who's who came in today uh was
like a freshman at Bentley and was
looking for something for the summer and
like we brought on people like that and
then we just try to keep people
um going the first like real hire we
made was uh on Halloween of 2016 so
we've been in business for like over a
year
and he was a meat guy uh this guy Mike
Billings and
um
I use LinkedIn once again and uh I
reached out to him and was like hey I've
got this business uh he had retired he
he ran Meat and seafood at BJ's which is
like Costco on the east coast and uh he
had retired he was like day trading on
the beach and was bored and I just
somehow stumbled upon his thing wrote to
him and he's like yeah I'll come talk to
you what are you searching for on
LinkedIn I've done this many times like
okay that's what finally you and I are
very similar that's what finally
happened like you're just searching like
what exactly the [ __ ] that I could
search that might be in their LinkedIn
profile so I could find this person
who's gonna do this for 35 years to get
on a phone call so I talked to him for
an hour and take all the knowledge and
and you say [ __ ] because uh like uh I've
been asked like well where'd you find
this guy I was like yeah I was pooping I
was just like looking on the internet
for this guy you know I was like I was
like all right let me just type in meat
and his his LinkedIn said experienced
meet executive
he was waiting for someone he literally
was waiting for someone to search meat I
got him on LinkedIn so this guy comes in
and he's he's like expensive he's like
wait you know my last company I made
over 200 Grand like I don't need to make
that much because I'll take some Equity
but like he he needs money
and at this point we're shipping like
10 000 pounds of meat a month jeez and
I'm like
okay so that's like a few thousand boxes
and I'm like we at this point it feels
like if we bring in somebody who knows
what they're doing
uh they can probably make up their
salary and we were also like we were not
sending a great product
um there was like we did this Groupon
one time and and there was like green
meat that we shipped out and stunk and
like we had to give all these refunds
and like I we we had no idea what we
were doing we needed like a professional
so this is he was the first professional
yeah but this is interesting because
you're like hey I had a bunch of like
interns yeah young people and like
people like chips on their shoulder and
stuff but like Omaha Steaks guy yeah
right totally Mike Billings yeah right
retired meat executive
those people are like pretty experienced
so it's almost like you kind of sound
like I don't want to give you too much
credit but like you sound like you knew
when to like hey we need just hungry
people who were like young and willing
to just work you know non-stop versus
like the experience like how did you
know when you needed which one so I
called this the barbell strategy okay
um so what I've found is actually the
further people are in their career the
more they act like the young hungry
people oh interesting and so like you
got like a 70 year old who had a 30-year
brilliant career but now I was like
super bored and knows freaking
everything all they want to do is come
in and like teach younger people so
these young hungry people are like hey
can I learn from you they're like yeah
great like sit down let me tell you
everything you know
um where where we've tended to have more
trouble and I don't want to say like for
those on my team who are listening this
isn't as big of a problem but like it's
kind of that like late 30s to early 50s
crowd where
um
really want to make a name for
themselves need to be moving up within
the company also want to coach soccer
all of which all this stuff is great
yeah like when you have somebody who's
super young and hungry and you can pair
them with somebody at the end of their
career either they had retired and are
doing another one or like are about to
retire
that's where magic can happen it's the
extremes it's like um I've seen this
over and over again so it's interesting
the way you're describing it but it's
like uh a lot of times Venture
capitalists which we'll talk about
whether you like them or not uh we'll
talk about like you want to find a
Founder who is amazing at one thing like
if they're amazing at sales or they're
amazing at technical ability or amazing
at whatever they don't need to be this
super well-rounded person a lot of times
just like be amazing at one thing
really what you're talking about here is
like oh this person has so much
knowledge that it's on the extreme end
because they're at the end of their
career or like this person is willing to
go above and beyond and work so many
hours and like be so tenacious that's on
the extreme of the spectrum the people
in the middle are actually the most
well-rounded people because they still
kind of sort of work hard right they
kind of sort of know what they're doing
like but it actually is like this very
weird Middle Ground which uh
sure there are plenty of outliers but
like that is maybe not the best place if
you want to have extreme outcomes like
you guys have had yeah yeah and if you
remember before I was talking about like
how my first company I left all the
people who helped hack Through the
Jungle uh in the jungle uh this time
around it was really important to me
that I was going to take all of these uh
interns or you know the kind of like the
younger people and teach them as we were
going so that they could they would be
able to drive a bus by the time that we
needed them to drive a bus and so that
was really important to me as to like
pair them with with older people grow
them help them to understand where like
where they might be blocked so that they
are prepared to take on big pieces of
our organization and one of the coolest
things about running a company
especially a company that has like grown
as much as we have is watching People's
careers just like Skyrocket you know you
come in as an intern and then you're
running a division of the company and
like you've just been really humbling to
see I forget who wrote this uh a while
ago but I wrote a blog post and I was
like what do you do if you're like
graduating college right and the
argument was like don't go work at the
big tech companies right you're just
going to be one of 20 000 people or
whatever uh and actually if you're
reading this blog post like you should
start a company because like you would
have already done it if that was who you
were the best thing to do is like go
join like a series B company that is
already heavily de-risked but still has
growth in front of it and so if you were
like early-ish at Uber or early-ish at
Airbnb or whatever like you get the
brand uh
um kind of recognition of the company
because of what it becomes eventually
you also learn a lot because you're
getting thrown so many different things
and if you're good you can move up in
the organization like you're describing
it's like it's this very unique place to
go uh where you still do get the
benefits of like growth in a business
but you don't have to take the founder
risk yeah and so like I always thought
that was like pretty good advice uh in
terms of like these young people where
they should go and you guys pretty much
for the last three years like fit that
almost perfectly yeah
um I totally agree with that advice
although I would say that I I personally
believe that um people should go into
sales first
um I just think getting your ass handed
to you every day having somebody say no
to you time in and time out is really
valuable
um and so if there's any
some people have sales experience
growing up like uh for example Mormons
um have to go spend two years on Mission
being told no over and over and over
um but I think having time in your life
where you are uh trying to sell
something and being told no constantly
is is pretty important I've never told
the story I think on this podcast but
you want to know one of the first things
I ever did in my like professional
career
me and three friends from high school
started a business and uh we were
getting local small businesses to sign
up for uh almost like a Yelp type
product for local schools
you know how we acquired customers I
don't know why I never thought this
before we would go to a shopping center
like we'd like look on the map and be
like all right cool like you two go to
this shopping center you two go to the
shopping center and we would just like
go store to store and we'd just walk in
and be like hey is the owner here
you can imagine like two 22 year old
kids walking in no uniform no like just
like off the street like it's the owner
here and the people at the cash register
are like uh do you have a weapon right
like who are you uh and again hindsight
like you learn how to talk to people
yeah right even if you're not successful
like you definitely learn how to
communicate with people you learn very
quickly like oh they're interested in
this to your point about like going to
Whole Foods like they don't want just
beef they want these other things or
whatever so that's actually pretty good
advice of like just get in front of as
many people as possible and get the Reps
yeah to learn yeah I think um you know
when when we went out to raise Venture
Capital we must have been in 50 meetings
where people are like no definitely not
I'm not gonna invest in that
uh there have been several times when I
tried to get a job in commercial real
estate I was sleeping on couches and
like you know just pounding the payment
being told no when we first raised money
while Bernie Madoff ran off with
everyone's money we were just told no
um and you know it just builds this
thick skin where you're just like oh
whatever I'll just keep going like I
don't care somebody's gonna say yes yeah
we'll just keep going until someone says
yes
as you think of the business today like
where is this going yeah right most
people like all right cool you get to 5
million they would just like don't break
anything right like just like let the
[ __ ] thing roll uh 35 million they'd
be like oh definitely don't break
anything everyone chill out a hundred
right now you're over 500 million
wherever you guys end up this year uh
do you just like run it for cash flow do
you uh try to get to a billion do you
take it public do you sell it do you
raise cat weight like how do you think
about the various options because it's a
great position to be in a profitable
business doing half a billion dollars in
Revenue but also sometimes like having a
lot of options actually can be tough
because you might not know what the
right kind of clear path is yeah
um so for the first few years I was
really enamored with the idea of
building this company and selling it as
fast as possible okay um so I did like
you know go talk to some grocery stores
and try to put together a deal and like
there was a moment
um probably three years in where I was
like I'm gonna sell this
uh and also there have been two moments
where I got almost a term sheets with uh
Venture Capital
um who were interested in investing and
I was like okay great and I could get
some secondary and like you know
whatever so
and every time it's Fallen apart
generally because I've I've trusted my
gut and I'm like this doesn't feel right
like I just need to back out
um and where I won't make you name who
it is yeah yeah uh well thank you
um where I sit now is
um I think we're in a really unique
position we have no outside investors we
have no one breathing down our neck we
can kind of do what we want
um and I believe that uh what I believe
in like what I believe the opportunity
is is I want to build an iconic brand in
meat if you think about the brands that
you know and meet like you probably
don't know very many and most people
know Brands and they're like yeah I
don't need that I know spam but I don't
eat that
um Tyson Tyson I don't know if you eat
that or not um but so I'm grass-fed yeah
good right exactly so you're like I know
that but I won't eat it right and so a
brain Tyson executive is watching this
like [ __ ] pop
yeah he said it not me just to be clear
just kidding I'm just kidding um
a brand that's like stands for doing
things right in meat is sorely needed is
a massive market and I think that that
is like what we have the opportunity to
do but like if you look at iconic food
brands like the coca-colas of the world
and the Oreos of the world and whatever
like they've been around for a hundred
plus years
are the brands iconic because they've
been around so long or are they around
so long because the brands were iconic
from early on I don't know okay but if
you if you start to go to school on like
what do these companies look like even
even Tyson like no tell me I'm in school
right now yeah what they what they look
they all are very closely held okay
family controlled okay multi like you
know on multi-decade if not 100 plus
years old
um and so that appears to be the
Playbook is that a key component to
making it last so long and being iconic
is that there aren't a lot of cooks in
the kitchen and it's like one family
usually Behind these things I don't know
maybe I mean some of them have gone
public but like the family still
controls it
um I I have no idea but when you look at
it you're like okay there's a pattern
here you know Mars huge company
privately held
um Cargill also a huge meat company
privately held
um so there's just like there's just a
number of these and uh I got really like
okay I think that meat is needs to be
transformed in this country
and I'm kind of like
I've gone from being like all right let
me sell this as fast as possible to like
I I think this might be my life's work
like if I could like spend my life
trying to change an industry where
there's a tremendous amount of suffering
in terms of the animals the environment
like the farmers there's just there's a
lot to fix if I could spend my life
doing that while running a big
profitable company like [ __ ] yeah that'd
be awesome okay this is a topic that uh
nobody wants to talk about publicly
behind closed doors I have many friends
all laugh when they hear me talk about
it
at dinners or you know or hanging out
whatever
they're like dude I hear this like
life's task or life's work or whatever
that's [ __ ] I just want to make
money or uh the thing I want to do is
like serve my customers but like I've
got 20 other ideas that I want to like
go build companies with whatever
Maybe
five years from now they're like oh this
is my life's work or whatever but like
the transition it's the same company
yeah right you didn't start out like
this is going to be my life's work you
kind of were like the opposite of the
spectrum and you're like oh this hobby
business oh maybe I could just like flip
it for some money and then like it grew
into your life's work it's like how do
you think about that in hindsight is
that actually the like more sustainable
path for it to potentially be your
life's work or do you think that no you
could start out from the beginning like
this my life's work and then just go uh
or you can do what you did like how
important is it to almost like have low
expectations and I recently read a book
and it says happiness is uh expectations
minus reality
and so like if you had like Hobby and it
turns into 500 million dollars in
Revenue like
you pretty much exceeded expectations so
like how important is that
um so
uh there's a really great book it's it's
out there it's called The Way of the
superior man by David data okay the way
of the superior man yeah it's I mean
just I wasn't an Entertainer it's like
um very graphic very sexual
um pretty misogynistic but but there's
some good content in there it's really
good
um one of the things that he talks about
is uh purpose okay living with purpose
he talks about men in particular I think
he's wrong that is just like really a
men thing I think it's men and women but
um
men with purpose right and one of one of
the images in the book is like this idea
that your purpose is like peeling back
an onion and so you might be on purpose
like my first purpose was like I'm gonna
prove that I can start a hobby business
and not raise outside Capital chip on my
shoulder and then you get to a point
where you're like okay that's done
what's next and it's like oh here's
another purpose inside of it and for for
me with butcherbox like butcherbox has
always revealed like another deeper more
important maybe not more important but
deeper purpose for me to be going for so
it went from like build a hobby business
to build a huge company that I can make
money to like okay like I guess I'm just
supposed to go try to transform meat
which seems like a really big
undertaking
um and I think that you know
oftentimes people
they want to think about this like
purpose way out in the future like this
is what I'm looking for rather than like
peeling back one piece of that onion you
know one of the things David data says
is like if you need to pee your purpose
is like you need to go to the bathroom
like you need to be on mission to go to
the bathroom okay great you've gone to
the bathroom what's your next like
purpose in life and thinking about that
like some purposes can be really fast
some purposes can take years but um
being on purpose living on purpose
um is far better at least for me than
the alternative and not knowing where
you're going
this is fascinating because uh ranjay
gulati who's a Harvard business
professor uh has a whole book podcast
Etc around purpose they went did a big
study uh companies that have a clear
purpose drastically outperform
businesses that don't uh then if you
read Robert Greene uh many of his
different books but something like
Mastery uh he talks a lot about life's
task right like what like you gotta
figure out what that is and then you're
off to the races uh if you then go and
you look at
um maybe somebody like uh so you have uh
range you've got Robert maybe you could
even look at somebody like a vivec uh
ramashwami I don't know if you've seen
him uh Drive Asset Management uh all of
these c-suites and and board uh of
directors Etc are becoming very like ESG
Centric and all the stuff and he
basically shows up and he's like listen
the purpose of this business to make
[ __ ] money right and so like cool I
get that other shareholders want you to
do other things that aren't actually
what makes us money as shareholders but
like here's my letter to the board go
make money and his whole thing is like
you can't serve you know five different
Masters as a purpose like you have to
have one and is it to make one of yours
it's not whatever and so like there are
these different data points throughout I
think business and Society in general uh
around purpose
but most of them are talking about
purposes like a singular thing what
you're talking about here is like the
purpose can almost evolve and in some
way your purpose got bigger and I wonder
how much of that is like you gain
confidence because you're like oh the
business is bigger oh there's more
profit like like I I actually have the
potential to do more whereas if you know
if you're sitting there uh Memorial Day
Weekend you're like I'm gonna change the
meat industry the intern might not even
come work with you right it's like how
much of it is like the success of the
business almost gives you more
confidence to like can I go a step
further yeah it gives you like
permission to say uh my purpose is
bigger yeah uh yeah so I um you know
going back to the very beginning I
definitely started searching for
grass-fed beef because I thought it was
a much better option environmentally for
the animal for the end consumer et
cetera
um and so I guess right from the start I
I knew that the industry was broken and
needed to be fixed I just guess I didn't
think that I would actually make a dent
in a massive super entrenched industry
but that's changing like that's actually
literally changing how big are the other
companies like the car deals or whatever
I mean cargo is 125 billion dollar
privately held company 125 billion they
do a lot of AG like valuation or revenue
revenue yeah Jesus they're the largest
or second largest privately held company
in the world
how big do you think they're meat
businesses
I mean meat is a multi-hundred billion
dollar industry in the United States
yeah just the United States but like the
lar is Cargill the largest uh there's
the big five so uh Tyson National Beef
JBS
um Cargill
and I'm forgetting one of them I'm sure
there's nice people that work on all
this oh totally when Texas Slim came on
the uh show he said a lot of nasty
things about all of them
not about the people but about uh the
way the businesses are run all those
these issues that you're talking about
so when you think about 500 million
dollars of Revenue yep does that make
you a top ten uh player uh top no 50 top
100 this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the eight sleep pod is the best
sleep machine I sleep on it every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you
can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
certainly top 100. um I I don't know
about Top 50 but when when okay so the
the the industry is
[Music]
um
so grass-fed beef is two percent of the
overall beef consumed in the United
States okay two percent out of 100 right
so um it's tiny uh and then that is
pretty much the case for the other
species like at the level that we're
doing so we do Humanity raise antibiotic
and hormone-free pigs and we do uh free
range organic chicken and we have a
whole bunch of wild caught seafood and
all this other stuff but each of those
markets are tiny compared to the
conventional market right and so
um
we uh we are a big portion of the
claims-based market as we call it but
what does that mean compare claims based
it's like so uh meet with claims so
grass-fed beef or antibiotic hormone
free or pasture-raised or non-GMO or
whatever those like claims are that's
just an easy way of saying like meet
raise better so we are a very a a large
portion of the meat raise better Market
but it's still like two percent of the
overall market so the people who are
really big in the space are the ones
that are like
um using confined feeding operations uh
using massive feedlots using massive
chicken houses like all the stuff that
you see the you know Undercover videos
for
um that is uh how most animals in this
country are raised
I got a lot of questions about grapes
first is are they playing both sides are
they like any one of the big five are
they like oh so here's like the regular
stuff and then oh by the way we also
have grass-fed well this is what's going
to play the game this is what's
interesting is like no so
um most most of those large companies
have
um not really built out any programs any
like grass-fed programs or claims-based
programs because they don't believe that
there's a market interest however
watching us and now that we're like a
little more open about our revenues like
watching us
literally us they're like oh wow there
there is a market here and so we're
actually getting like reached out to by
those large companies being like do you
want to partner with us like would you
be if we raised animals to this standard
would you be a buyer which is
fascinating it's like would you yeah if
it met the standard yeah because we'd
actually be changing the industry you
know I was asked recently like what do
you do what would happen if we're like
10 years in the future and these big
companies like all partner with you and
they all build out their own programs
and now they're bigger than you and
they've like squeezed you out and you go
out of business and I'm like
I don't know if I could get all those
companies to like actually change their
practices and do things the right way
like I think I've acted like I've done
my mission like I did it like that's
fine put me out of business like
whatever
um I'm sure I'll figure out something
else to do so start another hobby it's
okay I'll start another hobby it's fine
um so I I just I'm I I'm really
encouraged by you know we like to work
with two types we like to work directly
with small farmers and and help them to
like grow their business which takes
Capital it takes us
um cutting purchase orders saying like
hey if you raise your animals to the
standard we will purchase from you and
we're also really interested in in
talking to big companies and helping
them to like figure out how they can
like actually do this at scale and if we
have to be the anchor tenant for them to
scale a program like we're we're how do
you make sure that they actually meet
the standard like it sounds dumb but
like you can't talk to the meat you know
interestingly how do you make sure
interestingly so there's a whole bunch
of third-party stuff you do especially
around the human certification stuff so
all of our stuff is like certified human
you need to like make sure that it's
raised to the right standard there's a
few certified Humane certification
agencies
um antibiotics and hormones are an
affidavit it's written there's no test
so you can say like yep wasn't fed a
hormone wasn't fed an antibiotic
um uh does that need a change like do
you think that they should have a test
we've talked about like random sampling
uh our our product uh but what I was
going to say is interestingly like
unfortunately oftentimes as the smaller
players who get in trouble
Who start cutting Corners it's it's
rarely the large players because they
just have too much to lose and I I know
like you look at big Ag and you look at
the way they treated animals and maybe
that sounds backwards like that sounds
like you know I'm giving them a pass and
like but if you're if they're if they're
gonna sign their name on something that
says this animal was
treated this way the bigger you are the
more you have to lose right and so I've
unfortunately and we've worked with
these people like
we've definitely had stories of farmers
like their herd gets sick
right and you you got to understand when
you're a farmer and you're raising 50
head of cattle and you got a loan and
you're raising them to a grass-fed
standard and they get sick and so you
give them an antibiotic to like keep the
cow alive but now they're not supposed
to be in the program anymore because
they're a Fed an antibiotic and we're
never ever antibiotics so what do what
do they do sometimes they are forced to
lie yeah um and I'm not saying that
that's like a huge thing in our business
but it's definitely
um yeah yeah so so there's you have to
do careful monitoring of everybody uh
what they're doing and and I think we
can do a much better job of this uh
using technology which is really nascent
everything's done on paper it's a huge
industry where like millions of heads of
different animals trade hands and it's
all done on paper
yeah I mean what's crazy about this is
like
ancient Rome
right like people were literally trading
livestock doing all this stuff and like
sure we have like I don't know maybe
printed paper right about like like not
that much has changed from like the pure
like transactions not people laughing
they go all this other stuff change
whatever but like yeah the basic idea of
you're going to raise an animal and
you're going to sell it to somebody else
it's like still pretty archaic yeah very
um and there's there's really not a lot
of Tracking not a lot of uh
there's there's not a lot of data going
back and forth there's not a lot of um
you know I think that there's uh this
area is Rife for disruption
um I first of all the the so every cow
starts out exactly the same it's cow
calf for six months and then it's a cow
living on pasture for a year
and then after eight so 18 month old cow
you know 98 of them go to a feedlot for
the last six months and the problem with
the feed law is when you're that farmer
who generally they buy the cow at six
months old and raise it for a year the
problem with the feedlot is
um the feedlot is going to put corn into
the cow and grow it to be as fat as
possible in six months whatever the
price of corn is is going to dictate
what they're willing to pay that farmer
so the farmer is actually like at the
whim of the Commodities market and
they're just trying to like raise
animals and so I mean for years the
farmer has lost money on every herd that
they put through their Farm like that
that person
grass-fed is like hey don't sell to the
feedlot just keep it on grass
they could conceivably do it on their
own grass or they could like that that
is absolutely could be a program
the problem is that the farmers alone is
due from the bank
so they in order to get the next herd
they have to pay off the first herd and
so they'd actually can't keep the animal
for an additional six months nine months
just eating grass because they have to
get another herd and like this is a
problem that I think how big are the
loans oh millions of dollars yeah
because if you have 50 head of cattle
you know it's
or I mean that's a small herd
um yeah you're talking about a couple
thousand dollars per animal
um they can be big yeah
um and so I I actually think it's a
really interesting application for like
Bitcoin or for uh for crypto to like
because there's there's an increasing
value of that animal as it goes along
and if you can like marry all these
subscribers that we have who want
something raised differently and you can
marry that with like this animal that we
just need to break it through that last
stage you could have something really
special yeah is that something you guys
want to actually do yourselves lately
yeah partner with somebody yeah for sure
um and as you continue to do this can
you eat into or do you have interest in
eating into other parts of people's
grocery bill or is it just meat uh We've
we've we've started eating into other
parts of the grocery bill so we ship
Frozen in the mail
um and we really are looking at anything
that is
uh Frozen we've we've moved but not ice
cream
not ice cream we do sell smoothies on
our site uh we are talking about doing
dessert at some point ice cream's tough
to keep frozen in the in the mail okay
um which is why I wouldn't be like my
first product
um we uh have an egg like eggs egg bites
and butter coming out soon we've moved
into jerky so we're like we're doing
kind of things in the periphery but we
haven't done like frozen vegetables
um and is that because there's like a
health angle to it or that's because
like literally it's hard to keep frozen
or something like that
um it's really a capacity at this point
uh we actually are
um
going to be doing uh pet treats this
year
um which is has been highly sought after
from our customers
and it is it really helps balance the
animal it uses pieces of the animal that
don't get eaten normally by humans
um so it helps us like balance kind of
all the all the cows we're using so as
you're like watching this continue to
grow you get increased confidence kind
of if I just think of like it's working
it's still working okay [ __ ] like me we
have a business right
um
you can do all kinds of crazy stuff
right like like you have cash and you're
not beholden to anyone how do you
evaluate what to do and what not to do
yeah how much of it is the customer how
much of it is like we want to do this
like like we're excited about it how
much of it is like an economic decision
how much of it is something else like
just what's the framework yeah that's a
that's a good question so I think um
so we have a we have a purpose and we
have a mission uh our our purpose is uh
really more of a feeling and it's this
idea of being able to confidently feed
yourself and your family like something
that you trust right that you put this
you put butcher box in front of yourself
and you're like I know that they went to
the nth degree to like make sure that
this is the best possible quality the
best possible prize and they they did
all the vetting that I don't have time
to do the mission of the company is to
transform meat
um so when we when we decided on moves
to make or things to change or like
things to invest in or money to give
away to we're really looking at that
mission and that purpose and and
deciding like does this help us
transform meat
um
or you know so that's like kind of the
purpose Mission side or
um how does this help us be more
sustainable so we can live for another
year by helping us improve gross margin
or improve like the fundamentals of our
business
um so we actually uh last year the past
two years uh we opened a dry ice
facility uh so we opened a driver's
facility in Oklahoma City and we're
opening another one in Iowa and the
reason why we did dry ice was
um
first of all the machines are
comparatively cheap and they'll put you
on like a five to seven year like zero
percent down thing and you can
depreciate the entire thing in year one
so that's like pretty good financially
um and secondly if we don't have dry ice
we can't ship a box
like if we don't have bacon and you have
bacon in your box we can ship you the
box and be like sorry we ran out of
bacon here's your box but if we don't
have dry ice we can't ship and so it's
it was this critical bottleneck where we
we were really looking for like what are
the critical assets that might be Trump
hard to get in the future or that we'd
want to control in the future
um you think like uh big meat players
would like go squeeze you with the dries
well actually dries got really squeezed
over the past two years it's been wide
so at the beginning in during the
pandemic
um
so dry ice is made from CO2
CO2 is generally a byproduct from
manufacturing the number one thing
manufacturing thing that it's a
byproduct from is ethanol
because of the pandemic nobody was
driving their cars there was a lot less
gasoline being consumed so there was a
lot less ethanol being produced so
there's a lot less CO2 being produced
then Coca-Cola and Anheuser-Busch and
all these other guys were like trying to
buy it all up
uh and so because they need dry ice they
need CO2 for their drinks oh got it
right so CO2 became like hard to get
um and then all the dry ice uh when the
vaccine started shipping uh they were
all being shipped Frozen and Andreas and
so then there was just a huge a huge
influx of driest Demand with like small
amounts of driest capacity and so we
were one of the few companies that
shipped Andreas that like didn't really
have a problem I mean why didn't you
have a problem because we controlled our
own destiny we had our own tanks we had
our own CO2 we had our own agreements
with people already like when they put
in the tanks that they were going to
fill them at some sort of interval and
so where some some places even in the
facilities we were shipping out of were
like we ship this week we don't have dry
ice we just kept shipping because we
were able to control our own destiny
what else are you scared of that
somebody could like take away from you
oh
like what about the boxes
those are plentiful
uh yeah they're playing I mean we ship
in a cardboard a fully uh recyclable
corrugated cardboard box
um let's see what are we scared of that
people could take away plastic bags well
one of the interesting one of the
interesting uh challenges that is going
to come up is California just passed
this law prop 12.
um where uh it's an animal confinement
uh specifically pigs
um
and what that is going to require is for
pigs to be raised differently because
California is a massive Meat Market
we help to push prop 12 forward knowing
that it was going to hurt our supply in
the short term okay because why did you
do that uh because it just transforms
it's like it's where meat needs to go
shoot yourself in the foot to yeah push
the industry yeah and and so like that's
like kind of a window into how we would
make a decision like should we support
this
and it's like if if you thought about it
just like if let's say we were publicly
traded and we're like well that might
mean that we're gonna reduce our gross
margin and pork for the next five years
is like the industry heals itself you
could see where you're like yeah let's
let's actually go on the other side
let's like let's let's be against the
regulations our shareholders May Force
us to yep all right exactly like because
you have that fiduciary duties here
shareholders
um if you are private uh without outside
investors you can kind of be like well
what's the right thing to do here well
we think ultimately the reason why we
started this company is because we think
that picture being treated better so
like let's be on the other side of that
yeah even if it hurts our supply in the
short term what's your day-to-day like
like you you plus your employees own 100
of this business you sleep till like 11
o'clock in the morning
relax like what is like a normal day
look like totally
um okay so I have three young girls I
have uh two six-year-olds and an
eight-year-old
uh so my morning
usually I'm trying to get up before they
get up because once they get up it's I'm
like shorter to cook and preparing their
lunches and doing all the other stuff
it's just chaos yeah so if I can get up
I have a one-year-old and it's already
chaos yeah three girls six and eight I'm
good yeah so like if I can get up with
something like like like five uh spend
some time meditating stretching just
like writing writing in a journal
um that's a good day it doesn't always
happen but that's a good day uh then
they get up and from six to seven forty
five I am like on demand yeah you're
dead uh yeah
um just every request possible getting
thrown at me
um and then they're off to school and uh
so I'm I'm now trying to figure this out
we just opened an office I'm trying to
figure out like what does my daily
routine look like you didn't have an
office before uh we shut down our office
during the pandemic okay and then we had
a temporary space but I wasn't going
very much and now we have like a
permanent space that we have a long-term
release for and you're like going and
now I'm going yeah so I'm going to be
going at least Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday going to the office uh and then
Monday Friday I might stay at home and
just have like more thinking walking
whatever during the pandemic I would
just be taking phone calls and just
walking laps of this pond near my house
dude it was the greatest thing ever I
know it was amazing like I don't know
why
I enjoyed it so much but the ability to
like do the call and no one judged you
for like being outside yeah was amazing
yeah I still do that I can't stand being
on Zoom or teams or whatever and I try
as much as possible to just like be in
person or be outside I banned teams in
one of our companies yeah I I was just
like look I had it's too hard in the
counter invites there's no phone number
to call in easily so I'm out yeah I'm
out
um all right so what time do you go to
the office uh so yeah so I I work out
with the trainer Monday Wednesday Friday
um
uh so I work out with uh my uh old
CrossFit coach and we do uh both boxing
which I'm really bad at but learning
quick and uh just like strength training
okay
um just try to like beat myself up you
do that in the morning yeah do that in
the morning okay three times a week and
then on the off days I'm usually doing
um some sort of like cardio whether it's
a run or uh in in Boston
um Harvard University has a really old
stadium looks like the Coliseum and you
can do the stadium where you like walk
up the stairs and walk down which I try
to do several times a week I uh I played
football at Harvard not going to Harvard
against against Harvard and uh I
remember just being like holy [ __ ] this
place is like different there's no other
stadium and I know all of college
football yeah it's really cool yeah
um okay so you go to the office I would
say like I try to be home uh in time for
dinner okay
um dinner is usually like 5 15 at our
house okay
um I have an away message on my uh well
it's like a in in my the footer of my
emails that says that uh I try to be off
the grid between 5 00 p.m and 8 P.M okay
and then sometimes I get back on to
check emails but like uh if I kind of if
I reach out to you it doesn't mean you
have to reach out back out to me just
like it's just when I do my work
um so I try to be like kind of present
between five and eight just to be like
with the girls and uh enjoy that
what do you do during the day like Yeah
from nine to five let's call it yeah
what are you doing
mostly meetings
um so I have a executive team that I
work with and then I have other projects
that I'm working on
um The Innovation bucket uh goes up
through me because I really love that
stuff
um and I try to make a lot of time for
like ad hoc stuff especially now that
there's an office like quick 15 minute
like hey let's talk about this or let's
do this
um and then I just spend a bunch of time
trying to get the word out about what
we're doing whether it's being on
podcast or writing or just trying to
like push it forward
um but I you know I would I would say it
comes and go like productivity for me
comes and goes and waves like I don't
think right now I'm nearly as optimized
as I have been on the productivity front
uh I think I've got some work to do to
like get what what's the biggest thing
that you're like I know I'm doing this
but like I gotta change this
browsing Tick Tock
no or even like just like or even
Twitter I mean it's like um
I I don't know there when the pandemic
first hit my social media
um
like usage went way up and there was a
time where it really felt like I was
like like working because I need like
all this information was flowing it was
just like I I need to be doing this and
it now just feels a little bit more like
a luxury and not like necessarily like
as much work
um
the other thing is so there's this I
learned from this great CEO uh he has
like a rule of 10 which is that he will
only allow himself to do 10 things at
any given time and he writes them down
only ten
and so I've started reinstituting that
I've done that at other times in my in
my career as well where it's like
okay here are the 10 things I'm willing
to work on
um and you know so one for me is leading
leaders which means like I have an
executive team and I need to lead my
executive team so like what are the
initiatives that I'm doing this week on
that
or thought leadership like what are the
initiatives I'm doing on that uh and so
I think when I'm not in the space then I
can just have this big to-do list and
it's like okay it all seems important
and I don't know what to like work on
first
uh and I think prioritizing especially
especially like when things are tougher
prioritizing is uh a really good thing
to do yeah
um I recently read uh the practice of
groundedness
uh this guy Brad stolberg and uh one of
the things he talks about is like we
live in the state of hyper alertness
right because uh and even says like that
used to be a really important thing
because like you didn't get killed by
the Predator right but like now hyper
alert alertedness is something that like
our ancestors could have never imagined
we're just like touching an electronic
every five seconds uh and he's like and
somehow a society we've like convinced
ourselves that the more notifications
you get or the more emails the more
whatever like the more important you are
and he's like actually the people who
like really win the game or like people
realize like that's [ __ ] yeah and
like how do you separate but to your
point uh I got a lot of friends who run
a lot of different types of companies
and the people who I think make the best
decisions are it's not all the time but
like maybe once a week maybe half a day
whatever they can do they can step back
and just be like where are we going are
we like going in the right direction am
I like doing the things that I need to
unlock the team the product whatever and
like
it's counterintuitive but like I think
people are waking up to just how
important it is yeah yeah well I didn't
mention this but uh
I have uh tried not to work every Friday
since I started the company really yeah
um it started as like uh a way that I
was gonna hang out with my girls uh
because my my daughter was five months
old when I started
um but now they're in school and I'm
kind of like I don't think I want to
like
just load myself up with meetings so
it's my thinking day like it's the day
that I'm able to like really process
things put things together like you know
and when I'm with the girls it's like
I'm painting with them or I'm like
playing with blocks so I'm like being
childlike and also thinking and
I think um I think it's important
um when you're a CEO or when you're
starting a company I think it's
important to give yourself time to think
um because you don't need to be
scheduled up to the gills and you will
be if you don't protect your time like
it just it's just the nature of the
Beast Friday I do a very similar thing
but I call it output day and I try to do
no meetings or calls it's like nothing
that's like coming inbound and it's just
like I know when I get to the end of the
week there's a bunch of [ __ ] I didn't do
yet and it's like I can just mow through
it and sometimes it takes me all day
sometimes it takes four hours whatever
uh but I can focus on the things I think
are most important right
um and what I found is uh it's great
because like mentally you go into the
day thinking very differently you know I
violate the rule all the time but like
for the most part try to do it
um but the first four days of the week
get [ __ ] loaded up yeah and so like
I've always gone back and forth on like
should I actually have that dedicated
day where it really puts more stress on
the other four days because I know that
I'm not gonna have any of the meetings
or calls on Friday uh or would you be
better off kind of like spreading it
across five days and I I don't know what
the answer is
um but then I also have a friend who now
Thursdays he's doing something similar
but dude come on like let's line up the
days right so then like I need so I can
call you uh and so it's like funny
because I think again it's it's some of
it's thinking but also some of it is
just like if you're in meetings all day
like you don't I'd laugh all the time
like I don't do my email right and then
you're like [ __ ] it's you know five six
o'clock and you're like I have you know
X number of email that I have to go do
and you feel like you didn't do anything
all day right but you're like I've been
in meetings and now I have to do this
and if you don't answer then you know
people get blocked or whatever like it
gets complex pretty quickly if you don't
have a good plan I think to kind of take
on uh the responsibility yeah and I
think that we actually do this poorly as
a company as well like I think um so
we're about we're over 200 people now
and um I think as you grow as a company
you don't necessarily prioritize like
efficiency and so I hear all the time
about people just in meeting after
meeting after meeting and they're like
when do I have time to actually sit down
and think do any work and it's like what
responsibility do we have as a company
to like help people
navigate that you know I know what like
works for me but I need to like kind of
bring solutions to a larger organization
um is one of the things I well we really
want to work on for next year is like uh
efficiency because there's just too many
meetings with too many people who don't
need to be there who are just wasting
time
the executives
um how many of them were previously
Executives somewhere else versus like
this the first time they're being an
executive it's like split uh most of
them have been at this point most of
them have been an executive somewhere
else okay and your relationship with
them are like are you doing like
one-on-ones and like weekly check-ins
and all that type of stuff or are you
just meeting with them as like an
executive team together like how does
that work
um both so we meet as an executive team
once a week
um and then I do one-on-ones it depends
on like how long I've been working with
you for we have a new CMO and a new CFO
who I'm meeting with at least once a
week
um but then for some people who I've
been with for a long time it could be
every other week or something like that
uh
yeah it's really just making sure that
we're coordinated like are we in sync
are we coordinated do I know what's
happening
um
explain that more because I think this
is something I see uh even I do it but a
lot of uh first-time Founders they'll
set up meetings because they want
information yeah and it's like this is
an information meeting this is not like
an action you know me or we're not
getting an action coming out of this
meeting and uh some of them maybe like
the async type communication companies
have gotten really good at like oh
there's this Doc and like I can just go
there and see it not have to bother
anyone but like definitely companies in
office I still see it all the time where
people like set up a meeting and it's
like okay tell me what you're working on
or tell me what's going on right and
maybe they have an obstacle or a problem
that needs to be solved but for the most
part it's like literally one person
transferring information to another
person yeah like have you solved
avoiding that or not really yeah well I
think the best solution for that problem
is
um Yvonne chanard uh who's the Patagonia
founder had this thing called the 15-5
sometimes called the 515 but basically
it's a weekly update that you have your
executive team team or whoever is in
your direct line takes this supposed to
take them 15 minutes to write and you
five minutes to read the biggest thing
you have to work on is making sure it's
only 15 minutes because sometimes people
like write a whole book and you're like
dude no it's 15 minutes like set a timer
um but you know it basically is a list
of like here are all the things that are
happening here are the bottlenecks like
here's what I need your help on and they
do it every week and uh so Yvonne
chanard in his book
um let my people go surfing or I think
that's what it's called um that's what
it was all about is like the only way
that I can go surfing and my staff can
go surfing is if we have a common
understanding of like here's how you're
going to report upon your work here's
what's going to happen you know like
that has worked um I don't use that with
my executive team now uh because
um
the kind of people do that ad hoc like I
don't feel like I need to have like a
structured 15-5
um but that that has worked in the past
um at this company and my previous
company so
I get weekly reports from I don't know a
number of different people about
different things uh and what I found is
like it's helpful for me because I
obviously get the information or
whatever it's more helpful for them yes
because it helps them they have to sit
down they have to write like hey here's
what's going on yeah totally right um
and some of them are like it's mutually
beneficial and then sometimes I
literally tell them I'm like by the way
like I met with you on Wednesday I know
what's going on for the most part I'm
going with you next Wednesday right like
you write it down because you're going
to come up with here's the problem
here's two potential Solutions and what
I've noticed is the best people who do
it they don't do it in 15 minutes so
maybe that's something we should work on
uh but the specificity yeah right like
you can go back and you can look week
after week after week and it's like it
started out and it was like things are
great right and then it's like you know
X thing shipped and then it becomes like
an actual metric that moves week over
week progress like you can literally see
the Improvement uh and it just clarifies
thinking yeah which I think is super
important right so it's like how do you
get informed but also if you can help
clarify the thinking your whole team's
better yeah
yeah the other thing that we've worked
hard on is our our executive meetings or
our leadership team meetings where
um
I don't just want it to be like if I'm
going to meet with you or if I'm going
to get an update from you I don't want
to then sit in the room with all these
other people and like I know all the
information it's like this isn't worth
it to me like you guys me I'll just
you know do something else
um so it's like how do you get like
above and beyond just the update into
like what's really holding us back what
are the big decisions to be made and how
do we like collectively think through
that stuff I won't do the update uh
meetings like in a group because I get
it's just like becomes a claustrophone
yeah yeah right uh but the other thing
too yeah it's boring but also
um
I always want like an agenda beforehand
and I know it I know people get annoyed
but I'm like listen like again the
agenda and I'm almost like a little OCD
about I'm like well we're supposed to go
to this next Point like why are we going
over here and uh what I found is that
like the process is uh so important if
you want to be able to not be in the
meeting at some point like you know it's
being run correctly and uh the single
biggest unlock I think I've ever taught
any of the different teams how to take
notes
like it's like so stupid right but like
every team I've ever worked with whether
I'm an investor whether I start the
company whether I'm like brought in to
help or whatever
if you have a 10 people or six people or
whatever in the meeting
and nobody takes notes I'm like hey you
should just take notes and just email to
everyone afterwards yep and it's like so
stupid but then what you realize is like
everyone's like oh that's really
valuable yeah and it's same thing like
um another one is uh in the investor
updates it's all offenders I'm like
listen just put a section that says how
you can help and if there's nothing to
help let's say no asks right but like
investors are stupid and they scroll
through and if they don't see that they
don't know right they're not going to do
anything they might even respond yeah
the last thing I want to talk about is
investors you had VCS that you don't
yes why not what is your evaluation yeah
I mean you almost dated them again but
then yeah I didn't
um so for the altar yeah got super close
to the altar
um
well first of all I think like I think
Venture Capital uh as really important
for certain businesses like if you're
doing deep Tech stuff or you know
building Hardware or like there's a lot
of businesses where it makes sense to go
raise money it's also a great way to
learn if you're a young founder and you
don't know what you're doing and if you
can get people to give you money to like
go learn on their dime that's awesome
just know what you're signing up for and
what you're signing up for is like
you're on the Venture Capital train and
um you don't call the shots anymore like
you have a boss and so a lot of people
like it goes back to kind of like what
kind of Lifestyle do you want they get
into a business because they're sick of
working for somebody else they you know
work on it for a little bit and then are
like well people are raising money on
Shark Tank so I should raise money and
then they go and raise money and then
they get diluted and then they're
they're not performing and their
investors are mad at them and they're up
their ass and they're like this I'm now
working for someone else that's just an
investor
I didn't raise money plain and simple
because my first company failed and I
was like I'm just gonna do a hobby
business and like I don't need to raise
money for a hobby business and then it
got bigger and it was like well I just
don't think you know we're growing this
business I don't think venture capital
is going to help much
um you didn't have money problems at
that point yeah we I mean we've always
had money problems but I have felt like
the money problems have kept us sharper
okay
um and so you know as I was saying
before like our our whole marketing
strategy was born out of not having
money if we had money we would have we
probably wouldn't have found influencers
we probably would have just like started
roasting through money on Facebook like
every other box subscription company did
and so it really like that like the
decision to not raise money really
shaped the company that we have and I'm
so glad that we didn't because if we had
I don't think we'd be here anymore I
think we
um when Blue Apron went public and
started trading really poorly right
after going public all the capital for
box subscription companies just dried up
immediately and so if you were one of
these businesses that was running like
unprofitably and like just hoping for
the next VC round uh once once that hit
you were you were done
um and so like I'm an LP in several
Venture Capital funds I like am an angel
and a bunch of deals like I I'm cool
with people raising money and I think um
you know you find the right funds you
can have huge returns and if you find
the right companies it can be great
um but I think I just
it feels like
entrepreneurship has become a lot hotter
of a space in the past 10 years and I
think some of the things that people
believe about entrepreneurship are just
not true like you have to raise money in
order to be successful that's not true
you can build an amazing business I know
lots of people who have bootstrapped
boring businesses that are crushing it
and like I just think that that's not
really taught as an option it's um
another one is like lifestyle design
like I was saying before it's like as an
entrepreneur you get to choose the
lifestyle that you want to have
and this whole idea that you need to
like just be all about hustle culture
and like bust your ass 24 7 365 is the
only way to get ahead it's like [ __ ]
it's like I mean I don't know the first
time I held my daughter I was like okay
I gotta like re-prioritize here this is
because my first company I worked my ass
off I you know I was in every Saturday I
was like working late I was first one in
last one to leave like
and it didn't work like it all that like
it didn't work it's just like no matter
how hard I tried to push the boulder up
the hill the boulder wasn't going to go
up the hill in this business I'm like
all right you know I'm gonna like let go
of that I'm gonna hang out with my
daughter I'm gonna prioritize my health
I'm gonna like do other things and
that's worked really well and so I think
like
I don't know I just feel like the the
the entrepreneurship as it's being
taught right now is very much about like
you need to raise money and then you
need to like go bust your ass to like
make good on the people that invested in
you and I I just I think it's a road to
like anxiety and depression which is
unfortunately a reality with a lot of
Founders it's a road to diluting
yourself and I I just wish people would
um do a lot more consideration before
they just go and raise money yeah
I think that there's a lot of people who
are learning the lesson the hard way
yeah uh but also
um one other aspect is when you said
raise money and learn on other people's
time I do think that especially young
people uh they learn a lot from the
right VCS so there's plenty that are
absolute idiots and everyone knows who
those are for the most part
um but
there is this idea of like they like
basically they're paying you to some
degree no not really but like they're
paying you to teach you and so uh what's
fascinating is that there's very few
young Founders who bootstrap
I don't know why and like there are
outlier examples or whatever especially
like 10 20 30 years ago but like today
if you think of I don't know you and I
probably could rattle off 10 or 20
companies that we know that are
bootstrapped it's almost always the
second or your third fourth fifth
company it's people who've cut their
teeth
and I don't know if it's like oh I did
the VC thing so like now I know not to
do it for this type of business I don't
know if it's like I learned how to build
a business and so like on the third
attempt you know now here we go I don't
know what it is but it's always
fascinating to me that like a lot of
young you know young 20s let's call it
Founders they don't bootstrap and is it
because they're being told to go raise
money or is it because like there is
something about having already run a
business that makes you better suited to
to scale without the venture capital I
don't know yeah that's a great Insight I
mean I do think that it's helpful
um if you're young and starting out and
people are going to give you money like
take the money you know
um
uh just to understand what you're
getting onto you know a lot of people
will be like Oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
raise money but this is the last round
I'm gonna do is like that's not how this
works like once you're on the VC train
you're on the VC train you're losing
money every month you're officially
gonna run out right the other thing uh
I've thought a lot about
um if you if you look at many Founders
not all like Zuck it doesn't fit this uh
Bezos doesn't fit this but but there are
Elon Fitz what I'm about to say uh
they have a small like a single or
double then maybe they had like a double
or a triple and then they have some big
thing and maybe they're fourth physics
whatever company
every founder I've ever talked to is
like this is going to be 20 billion
dollar company and you're like I can go
count how many there are out there like
there's just not that many 20 billion
not companies uh so maybe like yes but
like would Founders be better off just
saying like hey I'm gonna go try to
build uh you know 100 million dollar
company and uh along the way if somebody
wants to buy for 30 million I'm gonna
sell it I'm gonna put you know 10
million in my pocket and like I'm a
[ __ ] genius if you raise money
exactly especially if you get into the
A's and the B's I mean it's hard to do
because people people give you money at
high valuations and then like selling
for 30 million dollars is like not
really an option anymore when you just
did 5 on 20 or whatever it's just
so and and forget to negotiate like that
you get to make the call at the end of
the day if you sell the company or not
because sometimes the VCS are the ones
making that call and they're like no
hold on to it um and so yeah you you end
up backing yourself into a corner pretty
fast versus if you can keep it small if
you just do like a seed round uh if you
need money or if you try to just
bootstrap
[Music]
um
it's an easier way to get that stand up
single yeah it makes sense where can we
send people to find you on the internet
if uh they want to learn more I feel
like you're a wealth of knowledge when
it comes to something thank you uh okay
so um they can follow me on Twitter at
Mike salguero
um
and uh yeah anyone can uh email me as
well CEO butcherbox.com all right don't
give out your phone number somebody
recently did that
so yeah call my office here's the number
give me a call I was like no please
don't do that all right thank you very
much I appreciate it I think people
really learn a lot from this we'll do it
again yeah thanks for having me